but we begin this morning with a
coronavirus pandemic once again
disrupting life in the u.s one week
ahead of christmas federal health
officials are seeing an uptick in cases
primarily fueled by the delta variant
with fears that holiday gatherings and
the highly infectious omicron variant
will create yet another surge the latest
outbreak is triggering a nationwide push
for americans to get booster shots the
average number of cases is up 26 percent
over the past two weeks hospitalizations
climbed three percent in the past week
alone all with omicron
presenting just three percent of cases
but omicron is well on its way to
becoming the dominant strain of the
virus in the u.s elise preston begins
our coverage here in new york this
morning elise good morning good morning
michelle mayor bill de blasio says the
omicron variant is in full force in new
york city more than 8 000 new cases were
reported here on thursday a record for
one day but the good news is that
hospitalizations and deaths are far
lower than at their peak in the spring
of 2020 that's still not keeping some
schools and businesses from stepping up
precautions
in the week before christmas long covet
test lines this one in miami may be a
sign americans are trying to play it
safe this holiday season trying to get
plenty of sleep loading up on our
vitamins
wearing our masks keeping our hands
clean trying to keep our six feet
and do our part 109 million people are
expected to travel over the holidays a
34 percent jump from last year with 6
million going by air
but omicron is traveling fast too the
number of states with cases rose to 41
this week new york city hospitalizations
are up 64 percent in two weeks and
although delta continues to circulate
widely in the united states omicron is
increasing rapidly and we expect it to
become the dominant strain in the united
states as it has in other countries in
the coming weeks we have about a
three-week window to prepare for this
next surge that's oregon's governor kate
brown yesterday i'm calling on one
million oregonians to step up and get
their booster dose by the end of january
the cdc put another spotlight on booster
doses yesterday when a panel said a
pfizer or moderna booster is preferred
over the johnson and johnson vaccine
because of rare instances of blood
clotting given the current state of the
pandemic both here and around the world
any vaccination is better than no
vaccination
with so many breakthrough cases in the
rockheads cast at radio city in new york
the entire holiday run was canceled
friday that follows nine broadway shows
and a surge in cases sucked plans for a
full slate of nfl games this weekend on
friday the league postponed three games
until early next week after more than 60
players on three teams tested positive
[Applause]
late last night the biden
administration's rule requiring
vaccinations for testing for employees
of large private businesses got a boost
a federal appeals court reversed a lower
court ruling to pause the nationwide
mandate the rule could affect 84 million
workers republican attorneys general who
sued to block the mandate say they will
appeal to the supreme court jeff elise
thank you very much from